[Applauso]
mi ci vuole un respiro per parlare di
cortocircuiti emozionali potrei
chiedervi di venire qui a guardarvi e il
corto circuito partirebbe allora mi
occupo di bimbi che non ce la fanno e di
bimbi che fanno fatica a scuola mi di
bimbi che fanno fatica a crescere di
bimbi che non si sentono capiti di bimbi
che soffrono e questo ha modificato la
mia storia la mia storia di scienziato
quindi l'altro giorno ero in un polo
apprendimento che dove aiuto questi
bimbi in questo polo apprendimento una
di queste bimbe mi guardava perché io
ero preoccupato su come iniziare oggi a
parlarvi in pochissimi minuti di cosa
facciamo noi e di perché sono qui e l'ho
guardata e le ho detto sai non so da
dove cominciare
lei mi ha sorriso mi ha detto
dall'inizio devi cominciare si inizia
sempre dall'inizio
e quindi ecco li vedete me in qualche
modo rappresenta il mio inizio il mio
inizio di scienziato e la mia partenza
per andare a studiare a capire che cosa
quello che da un certo punto di vista mi
ha affascinato per tantissimo tempo cioè
il rapporto tra il cervello e la mente
tra il cervello e l'anima tra cosa
sentiamo e come è possibile che sentiamo
così e quindi ho passato anni anni ad
affascinarmi per questa struttura
straordinaria al cervello è una
struttura straordinaria i millesimi di
secondo in questo momento voi avete
milioni di miliardi di connessioni che
mettono in moto tutta una trasformazione
di ciò che siete state di ciò che sarete
ea modificare tutto questo sono le
informazioni che stanno entrando e che
in qualche modo seminano qualche cosa di
nuovo che determina potatura in ciò che
voi siete stati fino ad adesso e nuove
generazioni questo miracolo che misura
un meccanismo che si chiama zona di
sviluppo prossimale è uno dei processi
più affascinanti della vita è quello che
rappresenta l'essere
gente che ciascuno di noi momento dopo
momento sceglie di essere quindi dopo
avere studiato tanto tutti questi
meccanismi sono tornata sono tornate in
italia e che cosa mi è successo che ho
incontrato un bimbo
l'ho incontrato in un corridoio verde di
ospedale le mura erano veramente
terribili danno l'idea di qualche cosa
che non curava ma opprimeva questo bimbo
aveva otto adulti insieme a lui oltre ai
genitori gli assistenti vari i docenti
vari gli ospedalieri e l'infermiera gli
ha detto che lì come andavo io quello
che io ho fatto è stato un gesto da
lontano in fondo al corridoio
cioè mi sono abbassata e gli ho sorriso
questo gesto ha fatto sì che lui sia
corso verso di me e mi abbia preso per
il camice e mi abbia detto quella parola
che leggete e gli ultimi ora io di
questo bimbo non so più niente
ma quello che so è che ha cambiato la
traiettoria della mia storia da
scienziato perché ho pensato che se
tutto quello che sapevamo non aiutava un
bambino e se una comunità intera che si
muoveva al punto di dargli otto adulti
non lo stava aiutando perché lui
chiedeva aiuto ad un è strano in camicia
in un corridoio verde d'ospedale
qualcosa in tutto questo nostro sistema
non aiutava e quindi mi sono rimessa a
studiare mi sono rimessa a studiare
quello che in termini così di di scienze
di deep science si chiama
neuroplasticità e in termini educativi
si chiama potenziamento della zona di
sviluppo possibile cioè ho cominciato a
studiare come si potessero esercitare i
domini cerebrali nel determinare
miglioramenti nel linguaggio nella
capacità di concentrazione di memoria di
attenzione e di intelligenza numerica
sono diventata brava brava al punto che
i bimbi cambiavano e da un punto di
vista di ricerche avevo grandissimo
successo perché a livello di ricerca
sperimentale quello che ottenevamo era
quello che si chiama proprio potenziale
migliore della struttura
neuropsicologica individuale se posso
darvi un esempio è il cervello gemma i
millesimi di secondo
le memorie che noi imprimiamo attraverso
le informazioni che riceviamo
quindi se vogliamo capire che cosa fa
per esempio la vita a scuola in un
bambino basta che facciamo un calcolo è
un calcolo che io diedi al ministero
tanti anni fa e cioè facciamo millesimi
di secondo per centesimi di secondo per
decimi di secondo per secondi per minuti
per ore per giorni per mesi per anni e
un bimbo sta scuola ottenete un numero
che tende all'infinito quel numero
misura quello che ciascuno degli adulti
che incontrerà determina nel suo
connetto ma la trasformazione del suo se
è un potere immenso e quindi mio figlio
in un tema in seconda elementare ha
scritto che sua mamma quando ha finito
di imparare di fare lo scienziato si è
messa a fare la maestra delle maestre
perché io ho cominciato a spiegare agli
insegnanti che cosa si determinava nella
neuroplasticità e nel potenziale umano
ed ero convinta di avercela fatta
ma non è stata così perché perché
qualche tempo dopo e in questo ci
avviciniamo al alloggi di cui vi voglio
parlare incontro un altro bimbo un bimbo
a cui avevamo ottenuto un cambiamento in
termini di profilo cognitivo
straordinario perché aveva recuperato
una deviazione standard e mezzo da
quello che si chiama genericamente
paziente di intelligenza generale e
questo bimbo ad un certo punto mi dice
ma adesso che mi hai tolto gli errori mi
togli che mi fanno male e io non ero
preparata a capire il rapporto tra
l'errore della mente e il dolore nella
mente e soprattutto non avevo riflettuto
su che cosa forse il meccanismo del
dolore ma se adesso io chiedessi a voi
mille persone adulte di ricordarvi della
vostra vita e dei vostri errori e non
intendo gli errori a scuola del leggere
scrivere e far di conto
ma gli errori della vita e vi chiedessi
se hanno una traccia più importante
nella vostra storia gli errori che avete
fatto il dolore che vi ha provocato e
che cos'è che determina la reazione in
voi
penso che la risposta sarebbe unanime è
il dolore che determina la risposta ma
cosa fa il dolore è per te spiegarvelo
in pochissimi minuti altrimenti mi
sgridano vi chiedo di dei gradi di
libertà cioè vi chiedo di fare quello
che in qualche modo ci aiuta a capire
subito datemi una pizzicata ma forte ma
proprio una pizzicata e vi chiedo questo
questo che cos'è dolore sofferenza e
dolore perché perché abbiamo milioni di
alert che dalla struttura che noi
andiamo a colpire ci mandano delle
informazioni neuro elettriche perché dal
cervello attraverso il sistema nervoso
periferico questo ribollito re
biochimico che produce energia manda
informazioni e dice allertati duole
perché ci dice ti duole perché ci
dobbiamo ricordare che non dobbiamo più
ricorrere a quel determinato tipo di
situazione perché ci fa male quindi va a
tracciare le memorie perché dice scappa
da di là che ti duole
allora cosa sono queste emozioni
straordinarie
ecco voi potete leggere sono processi
incredibili a livello neuro pulsionale
ai miei studenti lo spiego questori
bollitore biochimico che produce energia
perché noi dormiamo e produciamo 3
hearts siamo svegli come in questo
momento ne produciamo 9 ma basta un
emozione una goccia qualunque di
emozione come poi la che adesso provo io
e che fa sì che sebbene io spieghi
queste cose a contesti molto più
complessi io sia molto più emozionata
adesso perché uno scopo grande è quello
di parlare con voi alla fine ve lo dirò
e questa emozione è talmente potente che
sebbene al mio cervello sia molto
addestrato la mia voce la manifesta e io
non riesco a controllare la voce perché
l'emozione più potente del sistema
cognitivo è il grande decisore ed è un
decisore intelligente che però ha solo
due risposte e la risposta e mi duole o
mi fa bene
mi duole o mi fa bene le emozioni
nascono nel nostro sistema evolutivo per
dirci scatta se ci duole tieni e cerca
se ti fa bene è come ce lo dice ce lo
dice attraverso un meccanismo
straordinario di tipo e razziale se noi
abbiamo un momento un momento di gioia
abbiamo un picco e razziale in cui
l'onda che si manifesta è un'onda ad
altissima intensità ma breve breve breve
e perché è un'onda altissima intensità e
breve breve breve perché deve tracciarla
la memoria di gioia ma siccome la gioia
fa bene come ogni meccanismo che fa bene
il cervello lo deve cercare ancora e
quindi c'è la breve il momento di gioia
perché così si innescherà il meccanismo
della ricerca della gioia ma se invece
nella gioia noi proviamo angoscia ansia
paura allora l'onda è molto diversa
perché perché a bassa intensità sta
sotto soglia coscienza e non si fa
vedere dalla mente stalli sotto perché
perché deve dare una haller che dice
ricorda ricorda ricorda ricorda scappa
da di qua che ti duole scappa da di qua
che ti duole
ed ecco che i nostri circuiti vengono
percorsi da onde che dicono scappa
perché ti duole e l'energia che
produciamo e un'energia che ci dice
scappa che c'è dolore sembra che non ci
sia via d'uscita
e invece c'è come vi ho detto non è la
mente che controlla le emozioni non è
questa è una grandissima illusione da
scienziato cognitivo ad un certo punto
ho dovuto arrendermi provocate vi il
conforto per esempio come emozione ci
riuscite provocate vi l'intesa adesso
ordinate vi di provare intesa l'uno
verso l'altro non ci si riesce
ma guardate che abbiamo degli
interruttori e questi interruttori sono
catalizzatori non possiamo accendere la
luce qui dentro con la forza del
pensiero dobbiamo andare
all'interruttore giusto e l'interruttore
giusto per le emozioni lo dobbiamo
capire qual è per esempio se vi chiedo
per piacere guardatevi negli occhi l'un
con l'altro con intesa vai
per piacere abbracciatevi 30 secondi dai
coraggio
marco per piacere fatevi una carezza una
carezza di conforto ecco se adesso noi
misurassimo e misurarsi col battito
cardiaco misurassimo la temperatura
guardassimo indicatori come il colore
della pelle e l'acidità l'acidità del
sudore che è stata emanata noi avremo
tutto un cambio di indici perché noi
abbiamo attivato circuiti neuro
elettrici potentissimi e questi sono gli
organizzatori questi sono gli
interruttori pensate che 30 secondi di
abbraccio comanda l'amigdala di produrre
lo sito cina che l'ormone che determina
nel momento del parto la possibilità di
una donna di resistere al dolore
trenta secondi di abbraccio quindi come
dice mio figlio io adesso mi sono messa
ad andare in giro a spiegare alla gente
che ri imparare a guardare i bambini
negli occhi imparare ad abbracciarli
rimparare ad accarezzarli implica
mettere nel circuito delle memorie
permanenti che sono di emozioni che
costruiscono ben essere e non male
essere e acqua e pane la scienza è
ritornata all'acqua e pane e in quali
memorie vanno le emozioni le emozioni è
interessante perché mentre noi
impieghiamo tantissima fatica per
esempio per studiare per ricordare noi
gli andiamo in consumo di energia
le memorie che invece vengono
determinate da una traccia immediata
sono le memorie che tengono emozioni ma
se allora noi ad un certo punto nel
nostro corto circuito emozionale
facciamo qualcosa come quello che accade
sempre cioè mentre per esempio io studio
imparo faccio fatica sperimento ansia la
mia memoria mette in memoria ciò che
studio ma anche l'ansia con cui ce l'ho
messa tutta
io ritorno a prendere dal cassettino
della mia memoria ciò che ho studiato ci
riprendono soltanto le informazioni che
ci ho messo ma anche le mozioni con cui
lo tracciato e quindi l'ansia entra nel
circuito e diventa un informazione che
mi manda in corto e se io apprendo con
paura io recupererò la paura
e se io apprendo con senso di disistima
io riprenderò la disistima
ma se io aprendo con sfida me stesso io
riprenderò la sfida a me stesso e questo
vi ho detto prima per millesimi di
secondo fino a anni di tempi in cui il
sistema educante può determinare
inquinamento nei circuiti mentali o
pandemia di guarigione e io sono per
questa pandemia di guarigione anche
perché da persona di scienza quello che
devo leggere sono anche le scienze a
fianco e le ricerche sulle p genetica mi
hanno fatto tremare perchè perchè
studiando cosa accade ai topolini che
durante la gravidanza vengono messi
nell'acqua ghiacciata e poi vengono
fatti partorire ci si è accorti e sono
dei dati che ci devono far pensare che
non accade solo ai topi che i loro
cuccioli restano con l'allerta della
paura per tre generazioni almeno cioè
come se le memorie del dolore non
fossero soltanto individuali ma trans
generazionali questo significa che noi
tramandiamo per proteggere i nostri
figli ciò da cui si devono proteggere
quali sono le due emozioni più
preoccupanti e che preoccupano più me il
senso di colpa e la paura di queste non
vi posso parlare ma mi posso dire quali
sono le emozioni antagoniste al senso di
colpa al grande antagonista e il diritto
all'errore
se noi ci mettiamo in questa
consapevolezza che dobbiamo far crescere
i nostri figli nel diritto all'errore
nell'errore come un processo di modifica
e di miglioramento continuo cambia il
livello di consapevolezza abbiamo detto
sussurri e voci
beh se noi diciamo bravo bravo bravo
noi diamo informazioni completamente
differenti perché è l'emozione che
facciamo transitare attraverso
l'indicatore che stiamo utilizzando che
va a quel grande decisore gli dice
proteggiti o non proteggiti e adesso vi
racconto l'ultimo bambino perché ho
diciotto secondi
questo ultimo bambino vi dice perché
sono venuta qui facendo una follia tra
un congresso e l'alto
perché sono in partenza per parigi un
congresso sul cervello che mi mette
molta più ansia ancora quindi non è una
buona giornata ma allora perché sono
venuta qui ve lo dico con la storia di
anselmo anselmi un bimbo asperger ad
altissimo funzionamento cognitivo come
rayman per darvi un'idea l'ho incontrato
qualche anno fa perché i genitori due
medici mi hanno detto va bene tu aiuti
tanti bimbi nelle loro difficoltà aiuta
anche lui che parla quattro lingue
risolve problemi di matematica come se
fosse al secondo anno di università
disegna al duomo di milano in pochi
secondi senza errori ma basta guardarlo
e si agita e va in tutti quei
comportamenti tipici prototipi c delle
sindromi autistiche importanti e quindi
io non avevo mai provato ad aiutare un
bimbo in quella che è la zona di
sviluppo prossimale delle emozioni ma ho
pensato che in questo cervello
straordinario se le due strutture sono
strutture che è sincronicamente
collaborano io potevo aiutare le
emozioni con la cognizione e cosa ho
fatto
gli ho chiesto di segnare in un quaderno
tutte le cose che lui riteneva a fargli
paura angoscia metterlo in vulnerabilità
e ognuno di questo collegare la
strategia con cui vincerla questa
vulnerabilità
questa strategia non aveva importanza
che fosse particolarmente sofisticata il
più delle volte era una strategia del
tutto su a come battere i piedi a terra
battere e schioccare le dita ma questo
faceva sì che questo flusso di corrente
dell'ansia se ne andasse quindi lui ha
compilato quaderni e quaderni di queste
sue soluzioni ed è venuto a presentarlo
ad un congresso di insegnanti 100
insegnanti avevamo addestrato sentite la
parola lui a non avere momenti di
reazione non favorevole a tanta gente e
tutte le insegnanti a non comportarsi in
maniera di agitarlo ma ad un certo punto
mentre lui parlava una delle insegnanti
si emoziona si mette a piangere si alza
e applaude quindi tutte le insegnanti
100 insegnanti si mettono a piangere si
alzano applaudono si commuovono
quindi lui va in panico e mi scappa
dietro una tenda lo vado a prendere
abbattiamo per terra lo prendo per il
mignolo ci troviamo ad una cioccolata e
devo finire veloce veloce e alla
cioccolata lui mi dice lucangeli l'hai
visto il moltiplicatore dico no
veramente cosa vuoi dire
c'erano 100 insegnanti lucangeli alcuni
giovani alcuni non tanto quindi in media
resteranno altri 25 anni a scuola
ognuno di loro avrà al 25 alunni almeno
in classe quindi con questa ora di
lezione io ho aiutato nella mia vita
62.500 bambini e io sono qui per questo
sono qui e voglio dirlo perché voi mi
aiuti a te a fare della scienza
servizievole sono qui e voglio dirlo
perché voi mi ha aiutato a fare della
cee ci aiutiate perché siamo in tanti a
fare della scienza servizievole ea fare
in modo che si diventa molto molto molti
molti modi più di 60 2.500 persone
grazie vola vita
[Applauso]